look so this isn't a practical technique
but
I'm going to just show you
this side does that if I like this
if I go out
I might miss it
so this is the standard format so today
I want to add
this to tell me because I I could always
99 and then I'm gonna add the Tammy and
go in I'm going to move this one if you
want
this hand mustn't go any higher than his
head a lot of people
they don't realize they just go like
that and they're up there
if he's lower he'll be stronger
I need to take his vision at the moment
so that's why I'm doing that I'm going
straight for him then coming out here
so this is the entry
if
I'm a little slow and he comes and I get
him on the inside so if you feel a hit
on the aggressor
because I've I've used physical Force to
stop him so that means that uh
I wasn't quick enough
all right but it means that like with
the Maro to Door your ego still stopped
him where
I need to stop him on the way
to his head
I'm just about as he's about to leave
her you come here now
it comes down
it's got a path the other side of my
body
if I've got this wrong if I've entered
too deep in Pace
that hit my body if it's too far away
I'll I'll be lean if I wanted to share
and I guess that's incorrect
so the my the distance
it'll feel strange at first using a fist
and then opening
hey
but you can do it
does it pass I just need to pass that
side the hip
okay
many many years ago he said um thanks to
only like taking your coaching neck is
all the others hurt me or make me fight
so
so what um
what I'm doing there is I've
I've done all the technical but you're
still working on the technical I I'm
trying to work and I know what some of
you hire grades are also I try to work
on the spiritual stuff I can't work on
those senses
Harmony
power
if I keep going
hey
I've got you know I've got it yet if I
start if I do that
on powerful so some of you will have to
do that because you've got to go through
a learning curve
say
well I was on the floor but I didn't
actually no I feel alive I didn't I
don't yeah I'm all there all right
I don't want him to sort of like
already singing
what's going on
before I survive this he'll soon be
picking somebody else next time when
they're bowing money it'll be going
to say
so so don't do it too harshly but
um
it should be smooth
either here or fist
fist
tight down
this is what the weapons does for you it
means
it means you're working in unices
so you know that's the best senior you
are try not to look at
I won that one that time and I won that
one looked towards you know making it
smooth making it Pleasant
because
I always thought the technique is strong
you don't have to be
I don't know what you can see
I'd say but you should be able to see
the
feet moving at a certain point
not
yes I was looking at you I know it's how
you were stepping so most people will
step oh not entering
I'll take it down
you've got to hear and now your step
that's a step your turn hopefully that's
a step all right the weapons teach you
how to float you know when you're
receiving it
foreign
[Music]
taking their lights out you know like I
said my dad had a difference
float
hey
foreign
your body a little bit further
thank you